Hello, everyone.
Welcome.
My name is Craig Alleva,
a solutions architect
on the Google Cloud
Platform team.
I'm here today to talk to you
about some great ways for you
to deliver massive quantities
of content to your end
users in the most efficient
performant way possible.
Now imagine you've got
a killer application
running in the cloud
and millions of users
using your application.
Maybe that application is
serving high definition videos
of cats, or perhaps the latest
audio for some cool new indie
bands, or very likely, a
boatload of HTML, JavaScript,
CSS, or other.
You've got tons of content
to serve to your users.
And those users are accustomed
to getting their content
fix in milliseconds.
How are you going
to give your users
the experience they demand?
You're faced with a
number of challenges
when it comes to serving
large amounts of content
to your users.
First, your users are
located all over the place.
But the servers running
your application
may not be located
where your users are.
How are you going to minimize
the latency for your end users?
How can you make sure that the
video you are serving to them
will actually start
playing in two seconds?
Second, content incurs
internet egress charges.
These are fees that you have
to pay for transferring data
from the infrastructure running
your application to your end
users.
When the amount of content
you serve increases
in terms of size, quantity, and
number of users consuming it,
these fees could really add up.
Third, you want to make
sure that the performance
experienced by your end
users is unparalleled.
You don't want them
to have to wait
while a page loads or constantly
have video buffer on them.
Finally, you want to make
sure that your content is
served 24/7.
You need to make sure
that when a user is using
your application, the content
is actually there and not being
hit with errors.
Developers and
infrastructure folks
deal with these
challenges every day
and have leveraged
content delivery
networks to help overcome them.
So what is a content
delivery network, or CDN?
CDN providers offer a means
to push and cache your content
as close to your
users as possible.
By leveraging
relationships with ISPs,
a CDN provider often
has many points
of presence near your end users.
This helps minimize
latency to content
and reduces the amount
of network egress traffic
from your origin servers
since the data is now
being served at the edge.
With such a high number
of points of presence,
you also ensure high
availability and optimal
performance for your end users.
So how can you leverage CDNs
with Google Cloud Platform
to get your content
to your users
as quickly and
reliably as possible?
One way to achieve this is to
leverage Google's global CDN
when storing content in
Google Cloud Storage.
This is a fantastic way to get
content as close to your end
users as possible.
Google has a vast network
of edge locations.
Google Cloud Storage
essentially behaves like a CDN
without any work on your part
because publicly readable
objects are, by default, cached
in the Google Cloud Storage
network.
You can leverage Google Cloud
Storage to serve content
like video, audio, pictures,
or your entire web application,
provided that your data
is publicly accessible.
Another option would be to
leverage Fastly as your CDN.
Fastly is a world
class CDN provider
that directly connects with
Google's backbone via Google
Cloud Interconnect.
This means that Fastly
offers customers
phenomenal performance and
lower latency to content.
The Fastly Cloud Accelerator
provides a direct connection
between their origin
shield points of presence
to Google's backbone,
allowing Fastly
to accelerate any content on
Google Cloud Storage, Google
Compute Engine, or Google
App Engine to the user.
When a user first makes
a request for content,
the application attempts
to fetch the content
from the Fastly edge cache
at the edge of the network.
If it's not there, it
then requests the content
from Fastly's origin
servers, which are directly
connected to Google's backbone.
If the content is not
on the origin server,
the content is fetched from
the origin server sitting
on Google Cloud Platform.
From there, the content is
then delivered to the end user
and cached on the origin server
and the edge cache server.
When subsequent requests hit
the edge cache in the future,
the content will
be there already.
If content was requested
from an edge node that
doesn't have that
content in the cache,
it will fetch it from the
Fastly origin servers.
Now another option for
disseminating your content
would be to leverage
services offered by Wix.
Wix provides technology built
on top of Google Cloud Platform
for creating web
applications in the cloud.
Wix also offers a set of
services under the Wix Media
Platform for storing, serving,
uploading, and managing
image, audio, and video files.
These include services for
manipulating and storage
of images, transcoding,
conversion, and storage
of audio and video.
These services are available
via an SDK with Google Cloud
Platform so you can leverage
the services directly
within your applications.
In order to best serve your
content from Wix to your end
users, Wix offers the ability
to add a CDN for distributing
your content managed by Wix to
the edge for optimal latency,
improved app performance,
and overall improved
experience for your end users.
Whether you're running
a simple website
heavy on text and imagery or
you're serving video and audio
to your end customers,
leveraging a CDN
is a great option to consider.
You will improve the
overall performance
of your application, thus
improving the experience
for your end users by
getting content to them
in a speedy and
consistent fashion.
You'll often reduce
costs by reducing
the amount of outgoing traffic
from your origin servers
and offloading that
traffic to the CDN.
And you'll provide added
redundancy and resiliency
in case of outages
or system failures.
Now you know how to best deliver
your content on Google Cloud
Platform to your end customers.
For more information
on CDN options,
please visit the links below.
And be sure to
check out the rest
of the videos in this playlist.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]